catastrophic and deadly a volcanic
eruption in Central America is affecting
more than a million people
Guatemala's volcan de fuego or volcano
of fire exploded just before noon
yesterday at least 25 people are dead
authorities say an unknown number of
people are missing and potentially
trapped beneath the ash this eruption
spread thick black smoke and ash to the
capital Guatemala City that's about 30
miles away more than 3,000 people were
evacuated while a modest president's
last night called for a declaration of
emergency Don Dahler is here with a
desperate race to find the missing right
now Don good morning good morning rescue
operations are just beginning again this
morning after being suspended last night
due to the dangerous conditions people
living in villages near the volcano
didn't have much time or warning to
escape the lava flow we want to warn you
some of these images you're about to see
are graphic the devastation from volcan
de fuego was unrelenting as hot molten
lava flowed from the volcanoes banks
into small towns people scrambled to
escape but for many it was too late the
charred bodies of several victims were
strewn lifeless on the ground thick
black and grey ash blanketed entire
towns hundreds of rescue workers rushed
in to try to tend to the badly injured
and help anyone still alive but they
struggled to reach some of the most
rural villages AP correspondent Sonia
Perez is in one of the hardest hit areas
firemen say they excuse you people
screaming but they keep going to help
them because not everyone from my family
escaped said Consuelo Hernandez who ran
to a hillside from the incoming lava
when asked if some were buried she added
I would say so
hi rising volcanic mudflow destroyed
this highway bridge as several people
shot video they bolted away as the
molten rock got too close government
officials hesitated to call for
evacuations when the eruption began they
waited until lava began flowing down the
volcano's banks to urge people to leave
about four hours after the initial blast
this eruption spewed ash and rocked more
than 32,000 feet into the air
Sunday's blast was the volcano's second
this year and its most violent in more
than four decades the danger is not over
officials fear the death toll will rise
because so many homes are difficult to
access the country is already receiving
help from other nations with deliveries
of food blankets and medicine Norah all
right thank you so much